when you conceive who the film what came
up first like the concept of of farting
corpse or the emotional journey of the
story like what was the initial yes yeah
I mean your question kind of leads to
our answer which is like when people
asked us that it's hard to say like
what's the concept of a movie you know
like that there was one afternoon where
Dan pitched to me the idea of a a man
escaping an island by riding a corpses
farts and beautiful music playing and
him crying and and I thought that was
really really funny but thought I was
like we can never make that no one no
one will ever let us do it we should
never do that yeah
and so we kind of filed it away as like
a funny image that wasn't like a concept
for a feature you know but then much
later we came up with an emotional
journey for those two characters and we
got really excited about like well
that's a really unusual way to start a
movie and then and then we get to go
interesting places you know we get to
shake people out of their comfort zones
with that silly idea but the real idea
for the movie I guess was you know we
wanted to explore something Manny yeah
we wanted to explore something very
Universal and very simple but with
really odd and strange things because I
think it's it's really fun to kind of
remove the barrier between like you know
the low brow and the high brow and see
what happens when they mingle because I
think that's more honest to what real
life is like like life is a real big
messy thing where there aren't
genres and things like that and so when
we found we found that these two things
you know the the farting corpse aspect
and then the the aspect of like shame
and and the things that keep us away
from love you know like kind of furring
those two things together in the melting
pot was really exciting for us so you
guys were excited about what was the
response you had when you told people
your idea and that you wanted to make
this film yeah I kind of feel like we're
pretty great at pitching we just have a
lot of fun and we don't really have any
hard feelings when people say no you
know like it's like this movie's really
fun to pitch because we because there's
you know funny sequences we can describe
there's also like a lot of really
and all stuff that's like easy to talk
about you know cuz it comes from a you
know a real place we we started in music
videos and commercials and short films
and so we got the attention of some you
know production companies here in LA
some studios here and they would sit
we'd sit down with them for meetings and
they'd ask like so what kind of movies
you guys want to make and almost almost
just to see what would happen we started
pitching this idea of them just because
like there's no way you know Fox would
ever want to make this movie but that
that was kind of the fun of it just to
see what would happen and and so we
would yeah we would pitch the original
idea and they'd be like haha that's
really funny and we'd be like no but
then it keeps going and then we did like
thank you and start talking about the
heartfelt side of it and 99% of people
would say like okay that's funny but we
could never make that here until one
producer eventually like asked us why
haven't you written it yet and and and
then selling the joke got turned on us
and we go shoot now we have to make this
you know but it was it was it was really
encouraging to find one you know one
weird producer who who saw the Mary and
this and this idea and was we really
excited to kind of pushed us into
actually working on it it's been fun
yeah well I want to ask about the movie
I don't know how how interesting of a
question this is to you guys but how
much of the film is real how much of it
is and do you want people to see it as
real or do you feel like it's a fantasy
or or do you even do you not care about
that type of distinction at all the one
thing that we really wanted to make sure
was always palpable was the emotional
realness like whatever what the the
truth of the emotions was always the
priority for us and besides that the
rest of the film almost becomes like a
Rorschach test
depending on who's watching it they they
can kind of especially the ending you
know we've had a lot of people ask us
about the ending and it's been really
fun having them debate it right in front
of us and kind of it kind of shows what
kind of outlook you take into the film
right or like what we've like had people
be like oh I got a huge fight with my
boyfriend after the movie because he's
this is not me talking someone said this
that uh that like this girl thought it
was such a beautiful happy and
and then he thought it was such a
pessimistic delusional one because for
him it was definitely not real and for
her it was totally real and and I think
we we we knew the movie wasn't clear
enough that that there was that
ambiguity but for us making it we
discovered like we had to treat it real
you know like it wasn't it
it wasn't a useful exercise to make the
movie as writers and directors and keep
asking like ooh but this is in his head
or whatever you know like it was
especially for our actors we just have
the teller actors this is real yeah the
whole crew everyone we had to just be
like no Manny's doing that right now you
know like let's photograph it like it's
hot you know happening well and speaking
of actors how did you go about casting
how did you get down right - Paul Dano
involved in the film the odd thing about
this project is like you know most
people will say no but the people who
say yes are like so excited about it
that they that they don't need any like
like pitching you know like we sent the
script to Paul and he sent back like a
request to get on a Skype and he was
basically already excited to be a part
of the project he had some questions but
it was it was kind of like it's amazing
that Paul Deano was like our favorite
actor for his character and he also
happens to be like a like-minded weirdo
like he's like really he's got a really
strange sense of humor so he just
immediately understood what we were
going for and same same goes with
Radcliffe Radcliffe is such a strange
excited enthusiastic person and he he he
was he basically said like I don't think
I'm ever gonna get a role like this ever
again so you know like if I say no to
this you know like who knows you know if
I'll ever get a chance to do it so he's
very adventurous with with his his role
with how he picks roles and this was
just one of the the strangest things
that still had like a seed of personal
connection for him like he was still
able to connect with the character and
connect with the story so is strangely
easy to get the Apple they were just
gung-ho yeah and the the last thing
casting wise that was really important
was that we knew these guys would be
like working together every day
you know and not just working together
like you know
to put his hands in Daniels mouth I'm
like carry him around and undress him
and you know like it's a very intimate
you know partnership and so we we were
like really careful to cast the roles
one at a time and then make sure like so
like Paul endale knew each other and so
they they kind of vouched for each other
and they're like oh yeah like you know
he's not an [ __ ] I would love to be
in a movie with him you know that way we
didn't get two great actors but have
them hate each other and there's so much
even though it's very real there's a lot
of visual effects work you can see and
I'm just wondering like how how much of
that was on set how much of it was in
post cuz I mean even even things like
them water spewing out of his mouth and
the makeup it's like it's really these
are visual effects I'm just wondering
how to how do you achieve all those yeah
we we actually try to make sure as much
as we can we shoot things for real on
set so that we are reacting to things
that are actually happening in the
actors are reacting and they're getting
real performances and so like the the
water is really just we just stole the
same technique that they used in The
Exorcist
you know our visual effects which is
what you know yeah basically they they
they've created a mold of the inside of
Dana wreckless mouth with a little tube
that kind of kind of goes down the back
of his shirt and we just had to remove
the tube in posts and I think that's
most of our visual effects everything we
do is just like removing a wire or
removing a little finger that like know
what it likes usually him he's usually
one who's poking things so we just
remove his finger and post and it's like
it's the same things they were doing
back in the 70s and 80s except for now
it's a little bit easier to clean up
which is pretty great and I don't know
why more people don't do it you know and
the music's very unique in the film too
and and I know you worked with
Manchester Manchester Orchestra and
those are could you talk a little bit
with that cause it's very it's a very
minimalist scorer except for the very
end which is also a big choice I want to
ask about to just that kind of crescendo
is how was like working with them
yeah so the Manchester Orchestra is a
band we did a video for in like 2012 and
it went really well and we loved the
guys so we reached out to the lead
singer Andy about just writing
melodies because we knew the movie would
be sort of a musical and sent him the
script and he liked love loved it and
the next day sent us the song that's in
the credits and was like here's the song
I've been writing let me know what you
think and and basically like he became
the he and then Robert who's his
producer songwriting partner did the
whole score and and they ended up not
just writing melodies but writing and
recording all the songs and the entire
score and then they came out and we're
here for the whole mix so it became like
a 12 month job for them because they
they wrote em like five or six songs
before we shot and then throughout the
Edit instead of using temp music
whenever possible they would make us
stuff that way they didn't have to you
know do a sound-alike after we'd done
picture lock or something they were just
part of the creative process the whole
time yeah we're so lucky
yeah they really spoiled us but
narratively we knew that it was going to
be a man isolated you know both
literally and figuratively so we thought
like oh if the whole score was just
almost like the melodies in his head
that would be really interesting and
just create a more personal subjective
experience overall and so we told them
you can do nothing but voices and Bob
hitting your body smacking your face
hitting sticks and leaves and things
like that that was your palette and
that's all you can use but we don't want
to sound like college acapella you know
it was very important that the yuccas
college acapella is all about the voice
imitating instruments but we wanted the
voice to sound like the voice and so we
told them to you know yell so much that
their throats got raspy we wanted them
to sound drunk and we wanted to sound so
we kept we kind of made sure it felt
very much human and messy up until like
you said up until the end when sort of
the real world kind of seeps into their
fantasy and into their magical Eden we
wanted to bring kind of in more
traditional score to kind of make you
feel that transition and then in the end
it's kind of like a nice marriage of the
two you get the voices you get the
strings you guys you get all of it
happening at once
it just felt like it just felt like a
really fun way to use the music to
narratively
push the the film forward and what about
a cotton eye Joe and the Jurassic Park
theme what was what was the impetus for
using that in the film yeah I mean like
he said this the idea of the score was
like oh you would sing to yourself if
you were stuck in the middle of nowhere
but specifically we were thinking like
well you would sing like you know ear
worms you know songs that get stuck in
your head and so then we liked the idea
of like what if we take one of our least
favorite songs ever and then put it all
in our movie so that was kinda Nige oh
we almost it was between cotton eyed Joe
and then with arms wide open by Creed
was the two we were debating but cotton
eye Joe is actually like an old like
spiritual like a slave song from the
1800s so it's free you could put it in
your movie Jurassic Park is gonna be op
thats Jurassic park's actually a song we
love like obviously and whenever we're
brainstorming a lot of times we'll start
trying to like seeing the music or like
turn on a song but when we sing like I
always either sing Jurassic Park or
kissed by a rose in the rain yeah I'll
see you yeah I feel ya so that mean yeah
so that yeah we put Jurassic Park in is
because it's like it's my catch-all song
that's like any any time a movie's
supposed to be emotional I think of that
song well we're running out of time but
I want to thank you both for being here
so much and thank you for bringing the
film thank chorus thank you so much guys
see you guys thank you